I'm not the kind of guy that spends
hundreds on a last-minute flight to New
York tears across town and runs up six
flights of stairs to knock on my best
friends girlfriends door in order to run
off and elope with her based on one
crazy thoughtless inexplicably romantic
so what am I doing here Audrey I'm not
passionate I'm a fact checker for
Christ's sake soul mates how can I be
yours you barely know me and I barely
know you now your boyfriend I've known
him since kindergarten to throw all of
these years of friendship away based on
what some feeling that says I must be
with you or I'll die that only happens
in the movies but we're not in the moon
we are on MacDougal Street two blocks
south of Bleecker that's where we are
that is an indisputable geographical
fact and all the facts are pointing to
one thing we cannot do this because the
fact is you're in a relationship because
the fact is I just met you yesterday
because the fact is I'm not the kind of
man that falls in love that's a fact let
you see the problem the problem is
despite every fact I can muster I still
love you madly and it just defies all
reason
but I love you madly and I don't want to
I can't help